ce n'est pas la première pause de poteau
mais la 800e qui effectue ses ouvriers
ce chantier c'est le futur site du
constructeur automobile stellantis le
green campus dans un an il prévoit
d'accueillir plus de 8000 salariés leur
ambition est double atteindre la
neutralité carbone d'ici 2038 et
favoriser l'expérience employist le nom
green campus n'a pas été pris au hasard
et on va retenir les deux e en
particulier du green un E pour
environnement notre ambition est d'être
comme vous le savez pour stellentis au
niveau global carbone neutrol en
neutralité carbone à l'horizon 2038
deuxème aspect le second e tourner vers
les employés donc les femmes et les
hommes de l'entreprise et c'est de
proposer des installations qui
correspondent à un nouveau mode de
fonctionnement à des nouveaux modes de
travail ce travail hybride qui repose
sur une juste articulation entre le
travail présent sur site et le travail à
distance c'est un site de recherche
développement de de formation et
d'acquisition de compétences pour des
nouvelles technologies et permettre au
groupe et à travers le groupe toute la
filière automobile d'appréhender la
transition écologique et la transition
numérique ce projet de 300 millions
d'euros nécessitera au total 21 mois de
travaux le site réunira des activités
tertières et de Red jusqu'à l'heure
dispersé à véisi vill coublet et à
trappe alors à la ville de poissie ça va
bien bien sûr apporter alors déjà de la
notoriété de l'emploi et puis bien
entendu toute la consommation qui va se
faire surpoissier en plus et tout ça
c'est nous pour nous c'est c'est une
très bonne nouvelle c'est aussi très
important pour cette partie du
département des Yveline car le nord des
Yvelines ancien territoire industriel
qui a connu l'opulence dans les années
d'après-guerre est aujourd'hui un
territoire en difficultés économique et
sociale et donc c'est un des symboles de
son renouveau avec plus de 20000 m
carrés d'espace vert le green campus
veut s'ériger en tant que vitrine
environnementale du groupe et sera le
premier d'une série de plusieurs autres
sites en Italie en Allemagne et aux
États-Unis